darüber regt sich die blonde frau hier
wieder auf aber wenn sie diese bilder
sehen dann werden sie mir recht geben da
bin ich mir ganz sicher die alle bürger
wir müssen ja im flugzeug maske tragen
und werden sogar geweckt dass es mir
schon mal passiert wenn diese mal
verrutscht kein scherz aber
spitzenpolitiker wie robert habeck und
auch hauptstadtjournalisten die man hier
sind im regierungsflieger dürfen ohne
maske fliegen der grund sei dass alle
einen pcr-test abgelegt hätten wenn ich
aber einen mache nun ja da muss ich
trotz maske aufzählt wir haben jetzt
oktoberfest in münchen
und da gibt es keine maske pflicht aber
wenn ich heute bin ich mit dem zug von
münchen nach berlin gefahren und musste
vier stunden diese maske tragen und als
ich sie runter genommen habe weil ich
ein stück schokolade essen wollte kamen
die zugbegleiterin und sagte bitte
setzen sie gleich wie die ihre maske auf
wir kennen doch dieses doppel denken
schon aus der römischen zeit was dem
jupiter erlaubt es ist dem rindvieh
nicht erlaubt aus einem habe erlaubt ist
ist ihnen ihr mir nicht erlaubt